PROFESSOR: Today, we are
talking about the local behavior
of a crease pattern.
So you take some crease
pattern for some flat folding--
we're thinking about
flat foldability.
This is a foldability question.
I give you a crease
pattern like this.
I want to know, does it fold
flat, like this one does.
And we're studying
what happens locally
right around a single vertex.
So I didn't mention
graph terminology.
It's probably useful
to mention that.
These corners-- where all the
edges come together-- those
are vertices.
These triangles-- or in
general, some regions
divided by the
creases-- we call faces.
If we just sort of imagine
cutting a little disk
around that vertex and
seeing how it behaves,
we get a nice circular piece of
paper with some crease pattern.
And we want to understand when
those things fold flat and when
they don't.
Sometimes they do,
sometimes they don't.
This is kind of like a one
dimensional folding problem.
So let me write some
stuff about that.
So we get what we call single
vertex crease patterns.
So something like--
this is the example
I have made-- just
something like that.
That should be flat foldable.
So we think of having
a disk of paper.
It doesn't really
matter, but it's
going to be easier
to reason about
and think about a disk of paper.
Really, we just mean some small
region around that vertex.
There's obviously one vertex
in the crease pattern.
Let's say we have n creases
emanating from one vertex.
This pattern is
going to be defined
by some sequence of angles.
In general, theta
1 up to theta n.
If there are n creases, there
will be n angles between them,
say in clockwise order.
And let's see.
When we fold this thing
flat-- like in this picture--
we take this disk.
We fold it along all
of those creases.
What I'd like to
focus on is what
happens to the
boundary of the paper.
So there's this outer circle.
The boundary is a circle.
And locally, if you look
at one of these creases,
it's like folding the
circle in half onto itself.
And when you make all of these
creases, if you're successful,
you end up folding the circle
onto a portion of the circle.
So if you look at
this boundary-- which
is a little hard to see.
Why don't I trace it?
It's going to do
something like this.
So this is what the 3D
thing looks like blown up
a little bit-- and I changed
the angles a little bit.
But this is what a flat
folding would look like.
And I'm really just
focusing on how
the circle maps
around this circle.
So a flat folding of a disk also
folds a circle onto a circle.
So we have a flat folding on one
of these single vertex crease
patterns, we get a folding
of a circle onto a circle.
This is nice, because
circles are one dimensional.
And last class, we talked about
folding one dimensional line
segments.
A circle is just a little
bit more complicated.
It's different topology.
But we can use a lot
of the same mindset,
at least, as we did for folding
line segments onto the line.
In particular, you can see,
yeah, this is kind of circular.
But you could also imagine
unrolling it a little bit
and making it straight.
Something like this.
So that it lies on
a straight line,
if you just unroll that circle.
So you also get a folding
of a circle in some sense
onto a line by unrolling.
Now, at this point, I want to
mention a slight issue here.
I mean for this
unrolling to work--
if you're taking a circle
like this-- in particular,
you must make at least one
fold for this to be possible.
Because right now, if I
haven't folded anything,
I just have a big circle,
I can't unroll circle
onto a line.
I haven't collapsed it.
Yet here, I've made
it small enough
that it only occupies a
portion of the entire circle.
And so I can unroll it.
So this is true, as long as
I make at least one fold.
OK.
Technically, I need to
assume another thing, which
is that this thing came
from a flat piece of paper.
I said there were these angles.
And what I intended to mean is
that the sum of those angles
is 360 degrees, as it is
in a flat piece of paper.
But I'm not always going
to require this assumption.
It's what we care
about for thinking
about a crease pattern
of a flat piece of paper
and we look at each vertex.
This will be true.
But when we reason about these
single vertex crease patterns,
it's really useful to think
about, sort of in the middle,
this could get smaller.
So for example, you have
a pattern like this.
Let's say I just take these
two creases on the bottom
and I fold a crimp.
Because I know a cramp is
kind of a good thing to do.
So now I have what's
called a cone of paper.
The sum of the angles--
there's two angles here,
this one and this one.
Each one looks like
270-- no, not 270, 135?
In total, it's 270.
So the total angle there
is now less than 360.
This is what we
call a convex cone.
So if you relax this
constraint to allow less than
or equal to 360, then
we get a convex cone.
And today, I only want to talk
about flat paper and convex
cones.
We need this for the
induction, essentially--
for proving things
about the flat case.
In the textbook-- if you look
at this chapter on single vertex
crease patterns-- we
also prove or study
the case where the sum of the
angles is greater than 360,
which you could never
make from flat paper.
But hey, it's fun
to think about.
It's a natural generalization.
And all the things
that we do here,
you can generalize
to that situation.
It's just a little bit harder.
So what does it take to
fold a circle onto a line?
In this situation
of a convex cone,
where we make at least
one fold, our folding
is going to lie along a
portion of the circle.
We can unroll it
a little bit, get
something lying on
a straight line.
It's kind of like folding a line
segment onto a straight line,
if it was flat folding of one
dimensional pieces of paper.
But there's a lot
of differences.
I mean, they are similar.
But a lot of the things
we proved last time
do not hold in the
case of circular paper.
So I have a bunch of them here.
So one problem-- you
may recall before,
if we had a line segment and
we put an arbitrary crease
pattern, then we could just
assign a mountain valley
assignment, alternating
mountain valley.
And that would always
fold flat, no collisions.
OK.
In this world of having a
circular piece of paper,
that's no longer true.
For example, if you have
this kind of crease pattern
on a circle or in
the disk, it would
look like this,
those two creases.
You can't fold that thing flat.
It's not going to work.
We'll see exactly what
you need to forbid
for that to make sense.
Another example is
something like this.
I mean, if I tried to draw this
in the line, what's happening
is I have a short segment and
then I have a long segment.
So the problem is
those ends don't meet.
But even when the ends
meet-- like in this picture,
imagine these are
vertically aligned--
if I do this alternating
mountain valley pattern--
mountain valley assignment--
I can't join these ends
and make a circle, because that
would collide with everything.
So this thing actually
does have a flat folding
starting from a circle.
And I'm not going to try
to un-map it to a circle.
It does fold, but not like that.
Not with that alternating
mountain valley pattern.
There are other annoying things.
Let me tell you one
more on the proof side.
Last time, we had
a lemma that said,
if your crease
pattern is mingling--
which still is a
meaningful notion here--
then you have a crimp, or
an end fold in that case.
Here, of course, we
don't have any end folds.
Here, we also do not
get this implication.
Mingling does not imply
the existence of a crimp.
And where the proof breaks
down is if you have-- so
if you remember, our
parentheses from last time--
we had this kind of pattern.
And we said, well, you
keep going and either
on the left side, you have
a beginning open paren
or on the right side you have
a closing round parenthesis.
In either case, you've
got an end fold.
Now, this can actually
happen in a circle.
And so you have
nothing you can do.
So you could have this pattern.
There would be no crimp.
And probably, in that case,
you would not be flat foldable,
but in particular,
this implication fails.
So we have to do more work.
But we're going to get
the same kind of result
that, in linear
time, we can tell
whether one of these
things folds flat.
So that's good news.
So last time, telling whether
a crease pattern folded flat
was trivial.
The answer was always yes.
And now, it's not so trivial.
So let's start
with characterizing
crease patterns that fold flat.
Then we will go to mountain
valley patterns that fold flat.
It'd be great if I
could just say that,
but I mean here, of
course, single vertex.
So I give you one of
these sequence of angles.
Let's say it sums
to 360 or less.
When is it going to
be flat foldable?
And the answer is very simple.
Let me write it down.
This thing is going to be
flat foldable if and only
if the sum of the odd
angles is equal to the sum
of the even angles.
And, yeah, I'm implicitly
assuming and requiring
here that n is even.
That's something we'll prove.
So n is actually even and
minus 1 is going be odd.
And if you happen
to have started
with a flat piece of paper--
for the sum of all these things
is 360-- then of course, if
you have them evenly divided,
this sum will be 180 degrees.
But if you started with the
convex cone, it'll be smaller.
For this reason, a lot of
people-- or some people
call this the 180 degree
property, or the pie property--
if you like to think in
radians instead of degrees.
And we can do a
little example here.
This guy-- this crease pattern--
has a 90 degree angle here.
And it has a 90 degree
angle down here.
So the sum of those two is 180.
Those are alternating angles,
different parity classes.
This is 45.
This is the complement, 135.
And those also sum
to 180, of course.
One does only if the other does.
So it's flat foldable.
We're golden.
Something like this
is bad, because I
mean it's an even number.
But the odd angles do not equal
the sum of the even angles.
One's clearly bigger.
And this is a general property.
This is also called
Kawasaki's theorem
or Kawasaki-Justin's theorem.
They proved it in 1989.
This is pretty
much the beginning
of origami mathematics.
So let's prove it.
There's two things to prove.
One is that any flat
foldable crease pattern
has this property,
which is pretty easy.
And the other, which
is a little bit harder,
is that if you
have this property,
you really are flat foldable.
That's the full
characterization.
So let's start with
the easy direction.
If you're flat foldable,
you must have that sum.
OK.
So it's all about thinking
what happens at a crease.
So we're thinking
about the boundary
of this piece of paper.
We're thinking about the circle.
And what's happening on
the circle as you travel,
say counterclockwise
for some amount
of time, that would
be first angle.
Then you make a fold.
It's either a
mountain or valley.
At this point, we don't care.
Either way, you turn around--
maybe you turn around this way,
or you turn around this way.
But in terms as your
travel along a circle--
so we went theta 1
counterclockwise.
Now we're going to
go theta 2 clockwise;
then we're going to go theta
3 counterclockwise, and so on.
We keep alternating
back and forth.
It's much easier to
think drawn a line.
So we go to the right, theta 1.
Then we go to the left, theta 2.
Then we go to the
right, theta 3.
And I don't know about
the layering here.
I'm just drawing it in
terms of horizontal travel.
The y-coordinate means nothing.
In order for this thing
to be a flat folding--
to be a valid folding
of a circle of paper--
these guys have to have
the same x-coordinate.
So I don't know-- I mean,
the y-coordinates, they also
have to work out.
But we're not thinking
about the y-coordinates.
We're just thinking
about x travel.
We've got to get
back to where we
started if we're
folding a circle.
That's it.
So how much total travel
do we do, in a sign sense?
How much do we go right?
Well, we go theta
1 to the right.
Then we go theta 2
to the left, which
is like going negative
theta 2 to the right.
And then we go through
theta 3 to the right.
Then we go negative
theta 4 to the right.
And you add up this alternating
summation that must equal 0.
The other thing that I should
say is that n has to be even.
This is maybe obvious
at this point.
But we're supposed to alternate.
Every time we hit a crease,
we have to change direction.
And so in the end, it's
important that after theta 4,
we change direction
to visit theta 1.
If they were aligned-- like
if theta 4 went over here
and then theta 5 went
like that, and there
was an odd number of
creases, this would be bad.
Even though they're lined
up, there's no crease here.
You just went straight
from theta 5 theta 1.
You're supposed to change
direction every crease.
So also, n is even to
alternate directions.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
You already--
PROFESSOR: All right, good.
Clear?
This is pretty easy, once you
realize the angles correspond
to x-coordinates in
this linear space.
So why is this enough?
In order to show
that this property is
enough for flat
foldability, we need
to actually worry about the
stacking order of these edges.
We need to worry about
the y-coordinates.
We need to make sure that
they can avoid collision
with some mountain
valley assignment.
The good news is we're free
to use whatever mountains
and valleys we want.
We can stack things
however we want.
We just need to find
some valid state.
And our intuition, from
the one dimensional case,
was we should try alternating
mountains and valleys.
That seemed like a good thing.
It avoided collisions for
an open piece of paper--
for a line segment.
Of course, we know
that's not enough.
Here-- somewhere--
I drew this example.
So it's alternating
in the middle,
and then that last
crease is a problem.
But that's all we need to fix.
It turns out it's not so hard.
So we have a nice circle.
What I'd like to do
is cut that circle.
So here, I sort of cut
it and thought about it
as a line segment and
then I wanted to rejoin.
OK.
I'm going to be careful
about where I cut it.
OK, I want to cut at an
extreme left or extreme right.
It doesn't matter.
We can see here the cut
ended up being in the middle.
That's bad.
So how do I fix it?
What does extreme mean?
How do I tell--
given a circle, it's
a little hard to say
what extreme means,
because it's circular.
But if I take a
picture like this,
I've already drawn it
with nice x-coordinates--
I don't know about the
y-coordinates yet-- I say,
oh that's bad.
My cut point ended
up being non-extreme.
Well, this is extreme.
So cut here instead.
So what that means is
redraw this picture
with this being the cut point.
So maybe, this is the beginning.
So we go like that again
and now we wrap around.
So now we have this segment.
And now we have this segment.
And lo and behold,
it remained extreme.
And this is always true.
You can do this sort
of cut and rejoin
the ends that were
messed up before.
And you'll preserve
the x-coordinates.
The x-coordinates
aren't changing
when you do this kind
of transformation.
So there's a clear leftmost
and there's a clear rightmost.
You pick either one,
you cut there instead.
And now we have
this nice property
that it's easy to join
the ends, because it's
as far left as you can go.
There can't be anything
that penetrates,
because that would
be farther left.
Let me write down some
words corresponding to that.
So once we cut at
this extreme crease,
you can fold this
1D segment just
like we used to be able to.
So we can fold it flat
using the accordion fold,
alternating mountain and valley.
We know that works.
And then all we need to show
is that the two ends can join.
Those ends are the two
copies of the cut crease
that we did in this first step.
We need two things.
One is that they are
aligned and that's
where we need this condition--
that the sum of the odd angles
equals the sum of even angles,
which is the same as saying
the alternating sum
is equal to zero.
That tells us that
whatever we do,
the x-coordinates are
lined up at the end.
So they are aligned by the
assumption that we made here.
And you can join
without crossing.
So this is a statement
about y-coordinates.
And we know it's OK, because
it's at the left extreme.
So by this choice
of the proper cut,
there could be other things
that come right to the boundary
here, but that's considered OK.
That's not crossing,
that just touching.
Nothing can go farther
left because it
was the left extreme.
That's the end of the proof.
Any questions about that?
That's Kawasaki's
theorem-- Kawasaki-Justin.
I would mention just for fun--
this is sort of classic--
if you allow one of
these-- a non-convex cone,
where you have more than
360 degrees of material--
this statement is not true.
And there's one other
situation which can happen,
which is that the alternating
sum of angles is not zero,
but it's plus or minus
360 degrees, which is fun.
And you can see examples
of that in the book.
All right.
So obviously, if
you want to tell
whether a crease pattern-- or a
single vertex is flat foldable,
you just compute this
thing in linear time
and you know yes or no.
So crease patterns
are pretty easy-- just
have one extra condition.
What about mountain
valley assignments?
Last time, we looked at
mountain valley assignments
and we showed that crimps
and end folds were always
enough to fold any mountain
valley assignment that's
out there.
That will continue
to be true here,
except now we don't
have end folds.
Now, it's crimps all the way.
What does it mean?
So that is the flat foldable
mountain valley patterns.
We're going to prove
that crimps are enough,
but before we get
there, I need a bunch
of sort of warm up facts about
valid mountain valley patterns.
The first thing is just
counting mountains and valleys.
So even if you play with a
simple example like this one,
you see it as three
mountains and one valley
or three valleys
and one mountain.
In fact, if you have
a degree 4 vertex,
with four creases
emanating from that point,
those are your only choices.
You could try, for example,
making it all valleys,
and it-- I mean,
you can't do it.
It's hard to demonstrate.
You could try making it two
mountains and two valleys.
Maybe I try to do
mountain mountain here
and then somehow this is going
to be valley valley there.
It's no good.
But what's happening here is
that the number of mountains
and the number valleys
must differ by exactly two.
It doesn't matter who's bigger.
So the difference could be
plus 2 or minus 2, because you
can always flip over and negate
that difference, swapping
mountains for valleys.
But they always have to
differ by exactly two.
Why is that?
Well, this is--
yeah, we're again
going to think of a
picture like this.
We have horizontal travel
according to the theta i's.
We're also going to think
about the vertical picture.
If this thing is flat
foldable-- so I'm assuming,
it's flat foldable--
then this must happen.
This is called Maekawa's
theorem, by the way.
It was proved by Jun Maekawa
in 1986-- a little earlier.
Also proved by Jacques
Justin around the same time--
back before we were good at
internet and communication
and whatnot.
And there were little pockets
of mathematical origamists
and they found each
other basically
in '89, when there was the-- '89
was the first origami science
math and education
conference-- started
bringing these people together.
The last one was this summer.
Right.
So why is this true?
I don't know.
A flat folding looks
like something.
It has no crossings.
It has-- the horizontal
travel, we understand.
It ends up back
where it started.
There's also some notion of
layers and vertical travel,
which is a little
tricky to think about.
But the one thing that's
easy to think about-- I
mean, this forms
essentially a polygon.
It's like a really
squashed polygon.
And these vertical segments are
actually really just points.
OK, imagine.
That's just where
you turn around.
So it's like a polygon,
just stretched or squashed
down onto a line.
And we know some
things about polygons.
OK, as an end
vertex polygon-- you
know that the sum of
the interior angles
is-- whatever it is.
I always get confused
with that formula.
So I don't like
to think about it.
But one thing we-- an
easier way to think
about that same statement
is just think about how much
turning the polygon does.
So you start here, you
turn right 180 degrees,
you turn left 180 degrees,
you turn left 180, right 180,
right 180, right 180.
How much is it in total?
Oh gosh, do I have to add?
No.
It's so simple.
It's 360.
Right?
Just, if you think about
if you're going around
in a circle, any polygon-- not
just flat-- but anything in two
dimensions, the total amount
of turning you do is 360.
Or if you count backwards,
it's negative 360.
So this is the key--
something you should all
know about polygons.
If you look at sum of the turn
angles-- how much turning you
do at each vertex--
that will always
be plus or minus
360 in any polygon.
This is equivalent to the sum
of the interior angles being,
whatever, pi times n minus
2, which I don't remember.
But this is much
easier to remember.
And it's useful, because we
can map mountains and valleys
to left and right turns.
As I said, every time
this is a valley,
it was a left turn by 180.
Every time it was a mountain,
it was a right turn by 180.
So valleys, mountains,
right turns--
so I'm going to think
of that as negative 180.
Now, of course technically, it
could be the other way around.
It could be this is
negative, this is positive.
But I already have a
plus and minus here.
So it's symmetric.
So if we sum up the
turn angles-- which
we know is supposed to
be plus or minus 360--
the sum of the turn angles
is going to be-- we're
going to have 180 for
each valley, so 180
times the number of valleys.
And we're going to have
negative 180 for each mountain.
And so the 180's factor out.
And this thing is supposed to
equal 360-- plus or minus 360.
How could that be?
Well, the number of valleys
minus number of mountains
should be either 2-- for
plus 360-- or negative 2--
for minus 360.
So that proves the theorem.
And that's why, in a degree
4 vertex, one of them
has to be 3, the
other one has to be 1.
There's no other option,
because the total number is 4.
It's the only way to
get the difference
to be plus or minus 2.
So that's kind of nice.
But it's not enough,
unfortunately.
If I gave you a mountain
valley pattern that
satisfies this
condition, it still
might not be flat foldable.
That's maybe no surprise.
It's not like we had
such a simple test
for the one dimensional
case, which should be easier.
We had to give an algorithm.
We said repeatedly
crimp and end fold.
If you get stuck,
the answer is no.
If you don't get stuck,
you folded it great.
I love this eraser--
increases entropy.
Let me tell you one case
that is easy to think about.
Because it's nice.
It reduces directly to
the one dimensional case.
And that's what I
call the generic case.
Generic is this very convenient
term we use in mathematics.
It's actually really
tricky to define.
So I'd like to not
define it, if I can.
But maybe I should.
The simple version, which
is not quite enough,
is to say that all of the
angles in the crease pattern
are different.
OK, here, for example,
two of them are the same.
There's two 90 degree angles.
This is not generic.
It's just easier to draw.
But in general, I
mean, you imagine,
you just draw some random thing.
None of those lengths
are going to be the same.
Yeah, the alternating
sum is zero.
But that's it.
And that's what I--
the generic case
is that is the only thing that
holds true about these angles.
You can take the
alternating sum.
That equals zero.
If you take some alternating sum
of some subset of the angles,
that will not equal zero.
If you take a random example,
this is going to be true.
OK, just bear with me.
Suppose never any two
angles are the same.
Then look at the
globally smallest crease,
so globally smallest theta.
Say it's theta i.
So the picture is theta i,
theta i minus 1, theta i plus 1.
And what do we know
if it's globally
smallest and none of
the values are equal?
Then we know that
these two are bigger.
No big surprise.
Think about what happens if
this is small, these are bigger,
and you try to make these both
valleys or both mountains,
that's, of course, bad.
This is one of the
situations we had
in the one dimensional case.
I mean, really,
this is a circle,
but I can think just locally
about what's happening here.
So in this situation, one
of these must be a mountain
and the other must be a valley.
I don't know which
order they are,
but I know they're different.
And then I know I can
apply one of these crimps.
Incidentally, the word crimp,
Jason Koo was asking about,
like, why do you call
it crimp and not pleat?
Probably, I should
call it pleat.
But it's crimp in my mind.
It's been crimp in
my mind since 1998
when we wrote the 1D paper.
It was before I knew the word
pleat, so that's my excuse.
So pleat or crimp,
take your pick.
Crimp is usually
many pleats together.
That's crimping.
Cool.
So crimps, we kind of like.
Why do we like crimps?
We proved, in the one
dimensional case last time,
that if you make a crimp
and your original thing
was flat foldable, the new
thing will be flat foldable.
Good news is, that
is still true.
I told you, all these
things were no longer
true in the circular case.
It's still true in
the circular case.
Should I tell you--
Let me just remind you-- the
same proof works-- remind you
what the proof looked like.
We had a crimp, and we're
hoping to fold that first.
We know at some point,
these creases get folded.
But there may be
other junk in here,
or maybe other junk in here.
We'd like to get
rid of that junk.
And so what we did
is move this junk up
to here, which was always safe.
We moved this junk down to here.
And that was still a folded
state-- a flat folded state.
OK, remember all this stuff.
Therefore, we could have
folded the crimp first.
And then we have a flat folding
in this situation, where
this paper is effectively
glued together, which means,
it was safe to fold this
crimp and glue these
together and never
touch them again.
So that is still true
in the circular case.
That proof didn't really assume
anything about the paper.
Would even work for
like tree shaped
paper or something weird.
So if we can find a crimp, which
we can in the generic case,
then you just make a crimp,
make a crimp, repeat.
If you ever get stuck, you know
that the original thing was not
flat foldable, because the thing
you have is not flat foldable.
Why?
If there's no cramp
in the generic case,
that means you have two valleys
around the smallest angle,
and that's clearly bad.
So-- I'm not writing
a lot of details here.
Is that clear?
If I have an angle
that's surrounded
by strictly larger
angles, I know
there must be one
mountain and one valley.
Then I can safely make
a crimp and repeat.
The trouble comes in when
these angles are equal.
We never had to
think about angles
being equal in the
one dimensional case.
It didn't matter much.
We just said, oh, you know,
it's safe to make a crimp,
as long as this was greater
than or equal to this
and this was greater
than or equal to this.
That is still true; it's
safe to make a crimp.
But how do we know
that there is a crimp?
How do we know that there's a
mountain followed by valley?
We don't.
I mean, if they're equal,
this would be all right.
That's two valleys is valid if
these three angles are equal.
But I claim still somewhere
there's got to be a crimp.
There's no longer a notion of
the globally smallest angle,
because some of them are equal.
We've got to find that
crimp, but it's out there.
So we just need to
prove that it exists.
So to do that, we're going
to generalize this theorem--
Meakawa-Justin-- that number
of mountains minus number
of valleys is plus or minus 2.
That's true, and
it's a statement
about the sum of all the
angles-- all of the creases.
What I'd like is something
a little bit more localized.
And in particular,
we're going to think
about when I have a whole
bunch of angles that are equal,
how many mountains and
valleys can there be in there.
So it's what I
call local counts.
So while everything I said
so far is pretty classic,
this result was proved
in 2001 by Tom Hall,
so much more recent,
over a decade later.
So let's think about
k equal angles.
And I want that to be a maximal
sequence of equal angles,
so the ones right after and
right before are different.
And furthermore,
I'm going to assume
that they're bigger--
strictly larger angles.
OK, so something like that.
A bunch of equal
angles-- k of them--
bigger angles on either side.
This almost always exists.
I should mention-- so I'm
going to say something
about this situation.
But this situation should exist,
because I take the smallest
angle out there and then
I see how many friends
it has that are all equal.
If it's the smallest angle--
or it's one of the smallest
angles-- then the
ones surrounding
it are going to be bigger--
unless all the angles are
equal.
So there's one case, which
we'll worry about later.
It's very easy.
All the angles are equal.
In fact, I could tell you
how to worry about that.
If all the angles are
equal, then everything
is crimpable as long as we can
find a switch between mountain
and valley-- somewhere.
And because the number
of mountains and valleys
is plus or minus 2, there's
got to be-- so they're almost
in equal balance-- there's
got to be a valley.
It can't be all valleys,
can't be all mountains.
So somewhere,
there's a transition
between mountain and valley.
So you get a crimp out of that.
But otherwise, if they're
not all equal-- let's
think about k equal angles
surrounded by two larger guys.
Forgot how technical this is.
All right.
Then I want to look at
the number of mountains
and the number valleys among
these k plus one creases,
so within that range.
It's going to be 0, if k is odd.
And it's going to be plus
or minus 1, if k is even.
It's not plus or minus 2.
Intuitively, plus or minus 2 is
when you go all the way around.
Here, we're just
looking at a segment--
a portion of the entire circle.
Remember, this is actually
a circle somewhere.
And this corresponds
to, in the odd case,
you're going to be going in
the same direction afterwards.
In the even case,
you're going to have
turned around but
not a full circle.
So it's going to
be plus or minus 1.
There's a lot of
ways to prove this.
One way is to think
about convex cones.
So if k is even, and you
fold this thing-- let's see,
one, two, three, four,
five, six-- equal angles.
And then there's
the two longer guys.
They may not be the
same length, but that's
what you get in the even case.
So what I'd like to do is
just, in order to just reduce
to things that we've already
thought about-- I mean,
you could talk about
turn angles again,
or you could just say, hey,
I know Maekawa's theorem.
So as long as I could make
this into a circle, which
I can do by adding
that stuff, now I
have a nice circular--
it's a flat folded state.
There's no crossings
here, presumably
because this did something.
I don't actually know
that it's zigzagging.
It might do other stuff.
But it's not going to
cross what I just added.
So the number of mountains
minus number of valleys,
in total here, must
be plus or minus 2.
I only added one
crease-- this one.
So that's going to make
it either plus or minus 1
or plus or minus 3.
If you think about
it a little bit,
it has to be plus or minus 1.
And hopefully, that's
what I wrote here, yes.
Because I mean, really, we're
thinking about turn angles
again, I'm afraid.
Can't totally reduce it.
We just turned around here.
And we were about to
finish the circle, which
would make it plus or minus 2.
Before we finish the circle,
it's plus or minus 1.
k is odd.
Again, this might go
like that, whatever.
But, because it's an
odd number, these guys
are going in the same direction.
And so the total turn
angle here must be 0.
And one way to see that is to
extend it into a full polygon.
You know that it's plus or
minus 2 for this whole thing.
And I added two guys
in the same direction.
If I remove them, it's going
to go down to plus or minus 0.
That was a bit hand wavy.
But do you buy that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
plus or minus 0?
PROFESSOR: Plus or
minus 0 is 0, yeah.
You went from 2 down
to zero, because you
remove two identical guys.
So let me tie this all
together, because there's
so many little cases.
So I want to know what
mountain valley patterns are
flat foldable, single
vertex, m/v patterns.
I claim there is a crimp.
If it's flat foldable,
there has to be a crimp
that you can find to do.
Remember, a crimp
was where this length
was less than or equal to
this length and less than
or equal to this length.
And one of these was m.
One of them was v. That was
the definition of a crimp.
I claim such a
thing always exists.
The proof is two parts.
If all the angles are equal,
we know that these conditions
are always satisfied,
because everything is equal.
So we just need to
find an m followed by v
or a v followed by an m.
And by Maekawa's theorem, we
know it's not all m's or all
v's.
So somewhere, there has to be
a transition from m to v's.
So just use that lemma
theorem or the count property.
Otherwise, if they're
not all equal,
then I can apply this
local counts result,
take the smallest angle-- take
one instance of the smallest
angle.
There could be many of them.
Find all of its neighboring
friends that are equal.
Then I know that the next
angles before and after
have to be strictly bigger.
Then I know that the number of
mountains and valleys in here--
if I look at the
difference and it's
0, that means the
number of mountains
equals the number of valleys.
Therefore, there's
at least one of each.
And therefore, there's a
transition from mountain
to valley in there.
Because the transition
from mountain to valley--
like right here,
that's a valid crimp.
This guy's bigger;
this guy's equal.
This would also be
a fine transition,
because everybody's equal.
This would also be
a fine transition.
Any transition from
mountain to valley in here,
I've got a crimp.
The even case is a little-- I
got to think a little bit more.
k is even.
k plus 1, which is the number
of creases here, is odd.
And the difference between
mountains and valleys
among those k plus one
creases is plus or minus 1.
Think about it for second.
That means there's, again, at
least one mountain and at least
one valley.
Because k, to be even,
has to be at least 2.
We've got to have at
least three things.
So there's going to be at
least one of one and two
of the other, in fact.
And I just need one mountain and
one valley somewhere in there.
And then I know there has to
be a transition from mountain
to valley.
Otherwise, use local counts.
And in either case, we
get either a mountain
to valley transition or a
valley to mountain transition.
And I get it in such a way
that these inequalities
on the lengths hold.
So in other words,
that it's a crimp.
Therefore, any flat foldable,
single vertex, mountain valley
pattern has a crimp.
Make it.
And as I was arguing
here, just like last time,
that crimp will still--
after you do the crimp,
you'll still be flat
foldable, so repeat.
Cook until done is
how I like to put it.
Question.
AUDIENCE: What about the trivial
case of just folding a circle
in half?
PROFESSOR: The trivial case
of folding a circle in half.
All right.
That's a good question.
It's kind of a technicality.
One version would be to
say, that's zero vertices.
That doesn't count.
And we're thinking
about one vertex.
And as soon as
you think about it
as one vertex, which is
fine, then you actually
have two creases there.
So it's two creases.
And hopefully, this works.
Oh, I see what you're saying.
It's not a crimp.
That's a good point.
AUDIENCE: But then
it's flat foldable.
PROFESSOR: It is flat foldable,
and yet, there's no crimp.
Damn it.
All right.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: But it follows
Maekawa's, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I made a slight mistake here.
I said if all the
angles are equal,
then Maekawa says there's
at least one of each.
That's not true when n equals 2.
Then there's two of one
and zero of the other.
As long as you have more than
two creases, then this is true.
That's enough.
So you have to handle
this as a special case.
AUDIENCE: At the end
of your algorithm,
you're always left
with two of the same--
PROFESSOR: That's true.
This is an important
special case to remember,
because this will be
the final picture.
After you do a sequence of
crimps, this is the good case.
If your thing is
flat foldable, you
will always end up with that.
AUDIENCE: That's a
case where everything
is the same, smallest.
PROFESSOR: It's another example
where all the angles are equal.
So that's why this
is the situation.
It's either Maekawa and
you get a cramp here,
because n is greater than 2.
And here, I should say,
if n is greater than 2,
then this is true.
Of course the n equals 2
case, it looks like that.
And it had better be both
valleys or both mountains.
Otherwise, it's not going
to be flat foldable.
I forgot about that.
I should add it in the notes.
But it's in the textbook, right.
AUDIENCE: At the end
of the algorithm,
it's not going to be a circle.
It's going to be a cone.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
It won't actually
look like this.
At the end of the algorithm,
it's going to be a cone.
The two angles will be equal,
because of Kawasaki's theorem.
And they should still be both
mountains or both valleys.
But it's going to be--
we can see it right here.
So I apply my crimp,
and now I have a cone,
and there's two angles.
There's one here, which
has been fused together.
And there's one here,
which is the original.
They're equal.
And it's two mountains
or two valleys,
if I turned it upside down.
And then it finishes.
So that's the algorithm
in action-- two steps.
First you find this crimp here.
This is actually the
globally smallest angle.
It's surrounded
by bigger angles.
So it's really easy.
Then I have a cone with
two equal angles, which
is what has to
happen at the end.
And then I'm done.
Good?
AUDIENCE: Is that the
only way to do it?
PROFESSOR: This is
what always happens.
Oh, is this the only way
to flat fold these things?
No.
There are other--
yes, one of the two.
I think it depends
what you're counting.
If you're counting mountain
valley assignments-- I mean,
if you just want to know,
can every mountain valley
assignment be
folded by crimping.
Then the answer is yes.
That's what we proved.
But if you want to get
every possible folded state,
crimps are not
going to be enough.
The reason they're not enough is
because we're using this thing.
So, hey, here's some
hypothetical folded state.
We can rip it out and make
the crimp has been done.
But then there's a
folded state you're not
able to reach by crimping.
We need to work that into an
actual example, where crimping
forbids you from reaching
some folded state.
But I'm pretty sure one
exists because of this.
AUDIENCE: Could that
be more like spirals?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, maybe some
kind of spiraling thing.
AUDIENCE: Well, layering
takes into account--
PROFESSOR: Right.
What we're missing here is
getting all the possible layer
stacking orders.
So we're just trying to match
a mountain valley assignment.
We're not going to match
a target layer ordering,
because we simplified
the layer orders in order
to make crimps possible.
So crimps won't get you
some of the folded states.
But one thing you can
play with over here--
that has been played
with by Tom Hall--
is if I give you
a crease pattern,
how many flat foldable
mountain valley
assignments does it have?
OK, we have this nice linear
time algorithm to tell you
whether a particular
one is doable.
How many are there?
And there is-- if
you work through all
of the things I've shown you
in a little bit more detail,
you can recover-- this
was finding a crimp.
But you can actually
look at what
are all the crimps
that are possible
and actually count how
many different ways
there are to fold.
How many crimps you can do.
And then given those
crimps, how many crimps you
can go after that.
And in the same linear
time kind of algorithm,
you can figure out how many
different mountain valley
patterns are flat foldable.
That takes a little
bit more care.
I will tell you the extremes.
How small could the number of
flat foldable mountain valley
assignments be for a
given crease pattern?
Well, do you have
any guesses when?
When do I have the least
choice of where to make crimps?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We have three angles.
PROFESSOR: For general n.
Sorry.
But, yeah, three angles
or, I guess, two angles.
We really can't do any--
I don't have any choice.
But for general n,
how should I disperse
the theta i's in
order to make there
be very few possible crimps?
AUDIENCE: When there are
only two transitions.
PROFESSOR: When there
are only two transitions
between mountains and valleys.
All the mountains are together.
All the valleys are together.
That's right, if I was asking
a question about mountains
and valleys.
But I was asking a
question about theta i's.
So I want to count how many
mountain valley patterns there
are-- mountain valley
assignments that
are flat foldable for
a given crease pattern.
AUDIENCE: So if you
have a bunch of angles,
consecutive theta
i's are increasing?
PROFESSOR: All the angles
are consecutive increasing.
Yeah, that pretty much works.
In fact, what I need
is the generic case,
where all angles are
different and they never
become equal by folding,
which is what generic means.
So then there was only
really one crimp I could do,
which is the globally
smallest angle.
So actually, I still
have two choices.
I could do mountain then
valley or valley then mountain.
But I only have two
choices for that crimp.
Then I will have two
choices for the next crimp,
two choices for the next crimp.
In general, I get 2 to the
n possible mountain valley
assignments for
the generic case.
OK, what about,
what's the opposite,
where I get as much
choice as possible?
AUDIENCE: Isn't 2 to the n every
mountain valley assignment?
PROFESSOR: Yes, 2 to the
n-- no-- 2 to the n over 2.
Thank you.
Right.
There are 2 to the n conceivable
mountain valley assignments.
It can't be that big.
Every time I do a crimp, I
eat two creases, not one.
That's what I forgot.
Good.
It's still pretty big though.
It's like square root of
all the possible things you
could imagine are
indeed feasible.
What, from 2 to the n
to 2 to the n over 2.
When would I get the
most choice in crimping?
AUDIENCE: All angles are equal.
PROFESSOR: All angles are equal.
That's the opposite extreme.
And in this case--
a little messier.
When all the angles are
equal, the only property
you need-- and you can
see that from the proof--
the only property you
need is that the number
mountains minus
the number valleys
is plus or minus
2, and n is even.
As long as you have
that, we showed here,
you're going to
have-- on alternation
from mountain valley-- that's
a valid crimp, because all
the angles are equal.
And you keep going.
So it's just, how do you
disperse that many-- how
do I disperse n over
2 minus 1 mountains
among n different positions.
That's what this represents.
And positions, how do I pick
n over 2 minus 1 of them
to be mountains.
Or it could be n over 2
minus 1 of them are valleys.
And that's this factor of 2.
So it could have more
mountains or more valleys.
And then you somehow
place those among those.
And if you don't
know this notation,
that's just what it means.
If you want to know
using other notation,
it's like this, n over
2 minus 1 factorial,
over 2 plus 1 factorial.
If you don't know factorials,
I'll tell you about them later.
Cool.
So that's kind of the end of
the single vertex situation.
Yeah, I think I'll mention one
interesting open question here,
which I would love to
explore maybe in our problem
session-- which looks like it'll
be Mondays at 5:00, I think.
This is one vertex, and we
went through all this work
to solve a single
vertex situation.
And it's interesting,
as we'll see,
to think about locally
how each vertex behaves.
But you would think, if
you have a crease pattern
with two vertices, it
shouldn't be that much harder.
So here we have linear time.
How quickly can you tell
whether a two vertex crease
pattern is flat foldable?
As far as I know, no one
has looked at that problem.
Surely, we can do
it in quadratic time
but maybe even
linear time, I think.
It can't be that hard, I think.
In general, if I have a
small number of vertices--
say k vertices-- much
smaller than n creases,
is there-- for the
algorithms people-- is there
fixed parameter
tractable algorithm in k?
Or can I get something--
even getting something like n
to some function of
k, would be progress.
I think this should be doable.
But ideally, we
get a running time
that's exponential
in k and linear in n.
That would be my hope.
Why do I say it has
to be exponential?
Because in general,
if I give you
a crease pattern with n
vertices-- lots of vertices--
this problem is
NP-complete, which
is-- there's not going
to be a polynomial time
algorithm for it.
Nothing good.
We will prove that
next Wednesday.
So I'll hold off on
that a little bit.
But for two vertices,
how hard could it be?
All right.
I want to talk about
one related topic.
And then we will go
to origami design
and do a little bit
on the tree method.
But before we get
there, I want to talk
about local foldability,
which is a cool topic.
People tend to forget about it.
I really like it.
I think it would make
a cool project also.
It's a nice algorithm.
It goes back to Bern
and Hayes, 1996.
So it's also right
at the beginning
of origami mathematics.
And it's this idea,
all right, I give you
a crease pattern now
arbitrarily many vertices.
And if I ask you,
does it fold flat?
That's NP-complete--
intractable-- same paper.
But what if I ask you just
to give me a mountain valley
assignment that might fold flat?
Well, that's also NP-complete.
But if you actually
want it to fold flat,
this is really the same problem.
But if I ask you, give me a
mountain valley assignment,
so that if I checked
every vertex according
to this algorithm, at least
every vertex folds flat.
That would seem nice.
Definitely, I have to find a
mountain valley assignment that
satisfies these
conditions, that as I
do successive crimps,
every vertex-- if I cut out
the vertex separately,
it would fold flat.
This is the notion
of local foldability.
And there's a linear
time algorithm
to give you a mountain valley
assignment that ought to work,
in that at each vertex it works.
It still may not work globally
for some other reason.
But it's pretty good.
I think this would be,
actually, pretty practical.
I think in a lot of real
world origami settings--
when you're doing
flat folding anyway--
locally foldable is going to be
enough to be globally foldable.
That's a guess.
I don't know if it's true.
Consistent mountain
valley assignment,
if there is one, so that each
vertex locally folds flat.
Let me try to concoct a
small example that's relevant
here-- got to think.
Yes, I think that works.
All right, here we go.
I think this is in the textbook.
I remember drawing it
in the past three years
ago or whatever.
So here's a crease pattern
on a square or whatever.
AUDIENCE: The top
one should have--
PROFESSOR: Yes, it
should have this.
Thank you.
So this satisfies
Kawasaki's theorem--
that was the hard part--
because these angles sum to 180.
And it's symmetric all around.
OK, these angles
are the smallest.
They are 60 degrees.
This is an equilateral triangle.
So we have this-- not
quite the generic case,
but we have the
smallest angle is
surrounded by two larger angles.
Therefore, one of
these is a mountain;
the other is a valley.
That means that
these two creases
have to have different
assignments-- I'm
going to write a not equal sign.
One of these is a mountain,
and the other is a valley.
They can't be the same.
Also, these two
cannot be the same.
That's not possible.
Because I've got three,
it has to alternate.
You can alternate three times.
You can only alternative
at even number of times.
Two of these are mountains.
One is valley.
And then you've got a problem.
OK, so this thing is
not flat foldable.
And this algorithm
will tell you that.
Because it will say,
hey, I can't even
find a mountain
valley assignment
that could possibly
fold each vertex flat.
So this is a nice algorithm.
At least, it will detect
annoying situations like that.
So in order to solve
this, we're going to use--
and I'm just going to sketch
how this algorithm works--
we're going to use this
characterization and this idea
that we can really find all
possible mountain valley
assignments just by trying all
the possible crimp sequences.
Now, there are
exponentially many.
So it's not like I'm actually
going to try them all.
But I need to explore that
space of candidate crimps
and see what happens.
So the idea is kind of crazy.
The beginning of
the algorithm is
fold each vertex flat-- somehow.
I don't care how.
Just pick a crimp, do it.
Pick a crimp, do it--
separately for each vertex.
They're not going
to be compatible.
And don't look at the mountain
valley assignment you get.
But look at the crimping
sequence you get.
So here, let's do
a little example--
a non-trivial example.
So here, we have the peace sign,
and these two angles are equal.
They're smallest.
I could crimp this
angle first, or I
could crimp this angle first.
I have a choice.
So I'll draw both of them.
If I crimp this angle
first, I know these guys
are paired up in the sense
that they must be not equal--
one's mountain and one's valley.
After I do that crimp-- just
like in the real example
I had-- this angle
will equal that angle.
And these two guys must
have equal assignments.
They must be both
mountain or both valley.
In this situation,
these two guys
are not equal, if I
crimp this pair first.
And these two guys must
be equal-- equal now
in the sense of being
mountain or valley.
OK, so there are still
exponentially many
possibilities in how to do this.
But just pick one-- pick one
of these ways of pairing up.
You're going to pair up
each of the n creases
into n over 2 pairs.
And they're going to have some
not equal and equal signs.
So now, if you imagine
the general picture,
like here, for example, I
might get-- in this pattern,
I would be forced
to get not equals
and these guys paired up.
And in general, I want to
look at these kinds of cycles.
If I come into a vertex--
here's a vertex--
it's paired up with somebody.
So if I come in here,
I can go out somewhere.
And I come to this vertex,
it's paired with somebody.
So I'm going to just-- I
can keep wandering around.
And in general, there will
be a bunch of these paths
that you can follow.
What could the paths do?
They either close up on
themselves-- maybe things
are paired up in such a way
that you make a return trip.
Or it could be some other path.
Let me draw a dotted path.
It could come in
here, and maybe it
gets paired up with this guy.
Maybe it goes off to infinity.
It reaches the
boundary of the paper.
Those are the two possibilities.
You get paths, which
go off to the edge--
off to infinity on either end.
Or you could get cycles.
The cycles are the problem.
Because whenever I have a cycle,
I have a parity constraint.
For example, when
they're all not equals,
the length of the
cycle must be even.
If there were-- what's
the general statement?
It's like the
parity of the cycle,
which is whether
it's even or odd,
should be equal to the parity of
the number of not equal signs.
Something like that.
I've got a sheet here.
Great, I just said
"parity problems."
It's something like that.
It's either the
parity of the cycle
should equal the parity
of the number of equals
or the parity of the
number of not equals.
I think, number of equals.
Anyway, one of the two.
And you can just check.
I mean, you're forced.
If I say, OK, let's
make this mountain,
then this is either
equals or not equals.
It'll tell me whether this
is mountain or valley.
Just walk around the cycle.
Either you get a
contradiction or you don't.
If you get a contradiction,
we have a problem.
How could we possibly
fix the problem?
Well, when we made-- you
look at each of these cramps.
I mean, in fact, you could
look at each of these vertices
separately.
But you think about one of
these crimps and say, well,
could I have done
it another way?
Sometimes, there are crimps
that have other equal choices.
Maybe, there are a
bunch of equal angles.
And I could have done
a different pairing.
What happens when I try
a different pairing?
Well, instead of this
being in one cycle
and, let's say, this
being in another cycle,
if I pair these guys
up instead, I'll
end up merging those two
cycles into one bigger thing.
It could be a path or a cycle.
And the algorithm says, just
keep doing those cycle merges.
And if you get stuck, your
thing is not locally foldable.
That's the hard part to prove.
Otherwise, you will find
one of these patterns
that you can actually
resolve mountains and valleys
all the way through.
So let's say, so start with some
folding-- say local folding,
whatever.
I'm going to say with some
pairing of creases at vertices.
And merge two paths or
cycles whenever possible.
And when I say merge,
I mean whenever
you have-- what are the possible
things you could possibly
merge-- when you have at some
point during the algorithm
a bunch of equal angles, you
have a choice which of these
you crimp.
Obviously, the mountain valley
assignment is not fixed.
You can crimp any of them.
You picked one of
them, and it's sort
of merging whatever this
thing is attached to,
to whatever this
thing is attached to.
If there's something else that's
disconnected from that thing,
I want you to instead
merge two of them that
combines two different
connected components-- two
paths or cycles.
Merging means I decrease
the total number
of paths or cycles.
I combine two into one.
Whenever that's possible, do it.
You can prove that
if you have parity
problem in the
merge thing, you had
to have had a parity
problem originally.
And merging can only
fix parity problems.
That's the claim, and that's
what I will not prove.
Once you know that-- and it
doesn't matter in what order
or how you choose to merge-- you
just merge as much as possible.
And either the resulting
thing is OK or not.
And accordingly, you will
tell whether this thing
is locally foldable.
Sorry, I want to move
on to other things.
But I think this would be a fun
thing to actually implement.
It's an easy algorithm.
And it's, I think, a pretty good
test it for problems like this
that prevent flat foldability.
So let's move on from
foldability to origami design.
So a bit of a big transition.
And we're going to talk
about origami design
a lot more next class also
but just start it off today.
And the particular
algorithm for origami design
I want to talk about is
called the tree method.
This is probably
the oldest algorithm
for origami design,
in that people
have been thinking about it and
developing it for many years
through this period called
the Bug Wars, when people were
trying to design more and
more complicated insects.
It's like, well, I can make
an insect with six legs.
Oh yeah, well I can make
a spider with eight legs.
an insect-- a beetle that
has wings and horns and there's
thorns on the horns-- you know,
all these crazy things.
During that time,
there were a lot
of people thinking
about how do I
make more and more
complicated-- especially, more
limbs in my creatures
and very precise
arrangements of those
limbs, let's say.
And that is what the tree
method deals with and was really
formalized by Robert Lang,
who published a paper in '96,
describing it as a sort
of complete algorithm.
And it's still
not known for sure
that that algorithm
always works.
But that's what
we've been working
on-- me and Marty and Rob Lang--
for the last four years or so.
And soon, we will
publish that thing
and prove that this
thing always works.
But I'm going to describe the
algorithm without the proof
that it works.
And what it does--
I'll tell you its goal
from a mathematical perspective.
So it's interested in
practical origami design.
So we're going to start from
a square piece of paper.
It would also work
for triangular pieces
of paper or anything convex.
But squares are what
people usually care about.
Sometimes it's used
for rectangles also.
The idea is I give to
you a stick figure.
So that's formally,
it's a tree--
a graph without any cycles.
It's a metric tree, meaning
that I put lengths on the edges.
I know this length-- this
edge length-- is maybe
twice as long as this one.
So I really draw it with
edge lengths in mind.
Then what I want
you to do is find
some folding of a
piece of paper--
I should really be looking
at what I'm trying to match.
So here, here, this
goes down, such
that I want to find some folding
of a square paper-- in fact,
the smallest square
possible, so that when
I project-- like
this-- vertically,
the projection of that folding
is exactly that metric tree.
And this is called a
uniaxial-- this thing is
called a uniaxial base.
Let me tell you a little bit
why it's called a uniaxial base.
We're thinking about what
are called origami bases.
These there like the
beginning of origami models.
And most classic
origami models--
like more than 60 years ago--
start from one of these bases.
You've got waterbomb base on
the top left, preliminary base,
fish base, bird base
windmill base, and frog base.
I can't remember them all.
I have a little example here.
This is the waterbomb base.
So it's just very
simple crease pattern.
And why this is useful
is, it gives you
sort of four flaps of
paper to work with.
Maybe you make one
of them the head
and the other two wings
and the back one a tail,
if you're making a crane.
If doesn't actually
start not from this space
but from the other one.
But the same idea.
If you're folding a
crane, one of these
would be the head, the
other tail, and two wings.
This is great if you're
making a four flap animal.
And if you think
about its projection--
and it's easier to think
about in this other picture--
the projection of this
thing is a four limbed star.
You can see it's a plus sign.
All of them are the same length.
And so this is
actually something
you can get out of
the tree method.
You just give that
as your input.
You will get this 3D thing
and this crease pattern
as your origami-- as the output.
Let me show you the
program in action.
So Robert Lang
implemented this thing.
It's called tree maker.
It's freely available, open
source, all that good stuff.
And I'm not an expert at
using it, so bear with me.
But if we wanted to say,
I would like that star.
OK, now, I drew it obviously
not with all the lengths equal,
but it's ignoring the
lengths that I drew.
And they're actually
specified here.
So all the lengths here
are supposed to be 1.
And then I say, OK, optimize.
And then make a crease pattern.
And then show me
the crease pattern.
And there it is, exactly
the crease pattern
I made, although actually I can
see from the mountain valley
assignment-- because
this is not really--
this is not flat origami.
It made it this way.
So it's flat.
Of course, the projection is
the same-- still four limbs.
And so it's dashes for valleys
and solid lines for mountains.
But you can make
anything you want.
So let's say we want to
make-- I don't know-- a lizard
or something.
So the blue lines are the tree.
So here's-- can I do this?
Yes, there we go.
So here, I have a forearm,
a head, a foreleg,
another forearm, a body segment,
tail, and two hind legs.
Maybe I want to make that.
So I say optimize and then
make a crease pattern, and then
boom.
You fold that, and it will
have exactly that projection.
And assuming it did a
reasonable job at computation,
this will be the best
way to fold this thing.
And it's the
smallest square that
matches exactly that shape.
You get the best scale
factor between the size
of your piece of paper
and the target shape.
But actually, doing
that optimization--
the first step I
did-- is NP-complete.
So it's not going
to do it perfectly,
and we'll prove that Wednesday.
But the heuristics
are pretty good.
AUDIENCE: It finds a local.
PROFESSOR: It finds
a local minimum,
and often it finds
a pretty good one.
And sometimes you can coax it
to find better ones, but, yeah.
It's not perfect, but
hey, it's NP-complete.
So you can't do it.
This actually shows you what it
would look like in x-ray view.
And then you can say,
oh, that was nice,
but let's-- where is
my-- yeah, that was good.
But maybe I really
wanted the head segment
to be shorter length of 0.5.
And then I wanted the
tail to be really long.
And then you can optimize that
and find a crease pattern.
And it'll complain.
Because it's having trouble.
Oh, dear.
Demo effect.
I should have tried
this example before.
It's not-- oh, gosh.
It's one of these annoying ones.
I should say-- I should add
some feature like maybe a strain
split something, add a
little bit, maybe do that
and-- there we go.
I cheated, and I'll explain
how I cheated last time.
But if sometimes the
particular method
fails but you can fix it by
adding in another tiny limb
off the edge somewhere--
and of course, you
can then get rid of that at
the end when you're folding,
it only makes the
problem slightly harder.
And it'll still find a folding.
But we'll talk about
that next time.
And I'm way out of time,
so we will stop there.